there was this kid after school he
wanted to fight and like I never showed
up to the fight and so I regret not ever
showing up to the fight kind of you know
like I feel like I should have showed
up I think it becomes like a mentality
as you get older if you don't stand up
for yourself you know so yeah I think
for a while I I was not standing up for
myself so that's that's why I regret it
you
know probably being more genuine to
people less
sarcastic what's the you can't really
follow up with that I think I had trust
issues and I wouldn't let people in I
wish I would have been nicer to my mom
she passed away right before my senior
year and I just wish I would have had
time to tell her how much I loved her
and how good of a mom she
was yeah big one is uh having a core
friend group through the first 3 years
of it and doing everything with them and
then we let some drama get in between us
and uh I let them all get away from me
and still haven't had any Redemption I
lost contact with all of them and I
honestly think about them all every day
they stayed friends as a group yeah and
then I was just exiled and you still
think about them to the say almost daily
yeah yeah it led to a lot of uh trust
issues for me and things like that so uh
the one thing I regret is not being more
involved with the sports and
clubs and you know what we were poor and
so I got that aspect because we have to
pay for uniforms and whatnot and my
parents didn't have it and we were a
family of four girls and so how can I do
it and not my other three sisters and so
I just decided Well you know it's not in
the cards for me so yeah my children got
to do that though so yours is an
interesting scenario where it's like not
really a personal regret like cuz it
there wasn't really much you could have
done about it there isn't much I could
have done um now what I know I'm a I was
a I'm a retired teacher so I know
there's programs out there that would
have helped financially and you know if
I don't know if I knew what I know now I
would have been probably been able to do
that through some program so oh well I
would say probably wearing Foundation
that was 10 Shades Darker than my actual
skin that didn't match my neck and
wearing concealer all over my lips and I
would wear lots of mascara like
literally like spidery mascara my lashes
were like up to here they would call me
cake
face it was quite obvious it didn't take
much to notice I just honestly thought I
looked really good so my friends would
tell me but I didn't listen your friends
would tell you not to do it huh yeah cuz
when I first started wear it was when I
first started wearing makeup in like
grade eight or nine I don't know
anything about makeup so I would just
like go into Mac and like find the
darkest Foundation that would make me
look tan and like Jersey Shore Vibes you
know but just didn't match my body
honestly I feel like nowadays everyone's
so good at makeup like I feel like kids
don't go through that awkward face
anymore that is so true why is that it's
not fair they never go through any ugly
faces like they'll be like 14 years old
and they look like they're 21 and they
have their together yeah um I was part
of I was part of the ski team so I I'm
from upstate New York Rochester New York
and I was on the ski team and also the
ski club and I just remember those bus
rides from our high school out to the
out to the ski mountain which was like
45 minutes like everyone had so much fun
on the bus and I was just like stuck up
in my little corner against the wall
listening to my my Walkman or CD disin
or whatever and I missed out on a chance
of really getting to know them and I I
really liked them as people and I still
like them as people when I follow them
on Facebook um but I I just was afraid I
kind of assumed that they were judging
me um which I don't think was the case
you often you like lie to yourself you
know like you you have these beliefs
that are false beliefs and as you get
older and now I'm actually getting to be
40 years old right so as I get older I'm
realizing that I had so many false
beliefs that I was holding on to that
I'm learning that were wrong and I just
to get rid of them and I'm still I'm
still doing that today there's a couple
that I'm working on right now um and
just kind of be free and be yourself
like
yeah definitely not trying hard enough
like school is easy for me and I'd
rather like go make money or work than
go to school like the way I thought
about is like I start when I was like 15
I work at a Mexican restaurant and I the
first paycheck hit I was like I rather
work 8 hours make money then sit in
class learn about stuff I'm not going to
use so like I think that was a big thing
for me like not have my priority
straight because I think I could have
gone further than just join the Navy so
I think that's probably my biggest
regret uh not
graduating that I wish I would have
stayed in school and finished school uh
definitely dropping out and quitting
football for sure I had a son pretty
pretty early and I just thought that I
couldn't handle both you know a lot of
people think I'm not going to miss high
school you're going to miss high school
for sure as much as you hate High School
you're going to miss it just not taking
classes serious you know what I'm saying
not I'm not getting more girlss you feel
me not getting more GRS I I regret that
I regret that I didn't study
harder and when I graduated from high
school I didn't feel I was smart enough
to go to college with the rest of my
friends when in fact I was just as smart
as they were but I didn't have
confidence so I didn't go to college my
life turned out great because I ended up
working for the Airlines and I've had a
phenomenal life but I've always been a
little embarrassed that I don't have a
college graduation uh that I'm not a
college
graduate I regret pushing myself too
hard I regret like buying into the idea
that college was the only path doing a
million APS and grinding and kind of
losing myself because when I entered
College I was full of a lot of anxiety
and I realized that there were so many
other paths besides
just grinding through high school and I
think I could have lived my life a lot
Fuller at that age and then I learned in
college to relax and not be always
worried about trying to do the next best
thing or be the very best version but
just to loosen up and try things um that
wasn't me uh that I basically focused on
what everybody else was doing in high
school so but now I'm a boss and all the
rest of those they work at Walmart and
you know like the corner store
so because I'm a cool ass mother like
I'm a whole vibe so like that's just me
so I think that's why that's my regret
because I feel like if I was me back
then then I would have a lot a lot more
friends because you know we want that
belonging that sense of belonging do you
have advice for like some other girl in
high school right now girl be yourself
all the rest of them cuz guess what they
going to have about 22 kids on we Fair
working at Walmart and guess what you
going to be a boss period the one thing
I regret is spending too much time on
Facebook spending too much time on
FarmVille that game I can't the amount
of time I spent on FarmVille competing
with my relatives and friends was wild
uh getting in a lot of trouble I used to
fight all the time give him the ones and
twos Mike
Tyson Rocky B Bo but you know what I
learned my lesson I figured you know
violence is not the key and you just got
to you know just stay on task still
regret that I got in a fist fight with a
a
girl we were skating she came on she
probably liked me but I was whatever
young guy didn't realize she was messing
with me more so and wanted to fight me
and so we started fighting but I kind of
regret that in hindsight now uh ghosting
him in high school we went to uh prom
together my junior year and then I
ghosted him like right after that and
then a few years after high school we
ended up getting together here we are 3
years later and then so do you remember
how you felt when she ghosted you I was
just trying to figure
out why honestly it was right after prom
even what made you like kind of forgive
that and uh I I've had my own issues in
life where it's just like I wish people
gave me a second shot so I just gave her
[Music]
one not getting a boyfriend cuz I really
wish I had one right now being in a
relationship all of my high school
because I was young and should have been
being around with a bunch of people and
enjoying life rather than stuck with one
person who's going to cheat on you
anyway I regret that I had a boyfriend
that was jealous and it caused me to not
be as outgoing I kind of
just didn't want to get him jealous so I
didn't talk to other people and I regret
that I think one thing I still regret is
being too eager to love being too eager
to love and grow up instead of enjoying
the time spent in high school that you
never get
again and of course like those young
relationships I think teach you a lot
about yourself and about what you want
and what you don't
want but I think that
it's easier to to learn that through
your own experiences versus having to
learn it through somebody
else not going to the next level
honestly so I was playing sports and you
know I had the chance to go to the next
level and play for a college football
team but I didn't go because I was you
know living a high school life not
thinking of my future um the most
powerful thing I'd say that I regret
from high school is not standing up for
myself um being very shy and quiet when
I was young I just allowed a lot of
things to be gotten away with so yeah
that would be that would be my answer
yeah um I definitely regret not sticking
up for myself more standing up for
myself and not letting people really
hurt me and affect me high school sucks
and I'm really glad it's over and I'd
never relive that
again I wish I could have told people to
shut the up do you have any advice for
other people who have a hard time
standing up for themselves in high
school say the first mean thing that
comes into your mind when people are
being mean to you just give it right
back there's nothing good about like
letting people get away with things like
that and hurting you so yeah say stop
even knock it off like anything and if I
can share one more thing what I found
very important is it doesn't last
forever you feel like you're going to be
there
forever and it doesn't last forever and
there's so much more of your life I
actually feel really sorry for the prom
king and queen who you know that was
their top moment in life at graduation
from high school when there's so much
more there's just so much more there
really is yeah awesome so for I guess
for both of you has what has life been
like since high school it was only up
from there are you kidding me yeah yeah
absolutely finding your voice yeah
finding your real friends and people
yeah discovering that there is that
Network
out there um you know when I was growing
up we didn't talk about that a lot you
know families were shrouded in secrecy
and all kinds of stuff so you wouldn't
talk to your friends about things that
were uncomfortable most of your friends
weren't your friends in high school
anyway well that's true you know that's
true to it was just the people you were
kind of stuck
with yeah so yeah um it's not forever
it's not forever and that's really yeah
hi everyone thank you for watching I'll
be posting bonus footage from the
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next
time